If this is your first Christmas away from your children,
and you are dreading it and truly don't know how you're gonna make it,
I want you to know you're gonna make it.
I have four kids. One of them has down syndrome.
She had her first open heart surgery at 4 days old.
She almost died several times.
They had to resuscitate her back to life.
And when she was finally discharged,
they said, Mrs. Templeton,
this child at one time
was ten times sicker than even the sickest child in this hospital.
The cancer unit, the burn unit,
anywhere you look in this hospital,
she was 10 times sicker than their sickest kid.
And I did not think she was ever gonna make it.
And I but almost fucking broke down when he told me that.
Cause I was like, you reassured me this whole time,
and I was trusting in your words,
and you didn't even believe in your own fucking words.
But she was. She made it.
She's now in middle school.
She's fine. She's had many other heart surgeries and other things.
But what I'm saying is, like,
I understand feeling like. No,
no, no,
no, no, no.
You don't get it. I don't know how I'm gonna make it
if I don't see and hold my children on this day that, like,
is motherhood. Like who.
Who is Santa? Mom.
Who makes the magic, the Christmas Magic?
Mom, what do you work?
So hard. All year long.
All year long, you're using Santa as an excuse.
And then this one day is the day that you don't get to see your kids.
And you know that somebody else is taking joy and pleasure in that.
They're.
They're not gonna enjoy the day the way that you would enjoy the day.
The. So you.
You know what I mean?
And you're pissed that they're doing it to take it away from you,
not to enjoy it. That's. Do you know what I mean?
You're super valid in feeling all the hurt feelings.
And I think the more you try to escape them,
the more they chase you. So
you need to just spend a good amount of time crying
and feeling like shit
and, like,
checking in with yourself and see what do you need.
Do you know what I mean? On Christmas Day,
you could. I truly drove.
Drove to the mountains and walked around,
like, a snowy little hiking path
because I didn't wanna see anything Christmas Eve I didn't wanna do.
And that's okay. You can do that.
Like, do whatever the fuck it is that you wanna do.
Sleep in bed all day, do whatever.
And you know what?
I kind of found a little joy in, like,
holy shit, this day is usually pretty fucking exhausting,
and I actually,
you know, I was so fucking sad and depressed,
I didn't do much. Fuck.
This is actually kind of nice.
So you do get to a place where you'll feel better.
You do get to a place where you find,
like, peace,
and it doesn't sting as much.
And I just want to encourage you to keep going.
You're gonna. You're gonna be okay, and you'll make it.